we think too much in silos so the
fitness guy things in terms of fitness
as so and the food guys are girl things
in terms of food and then I think of
sleep and so the meditation things of
meditation
I actually think as so they are so
interconnected and so that we need to
have at least a few people thinking on
what if we take the more a helicopter
view or more holistic approach and so
that is actually has a tagging all of
these things or at least connecting the
dots hey everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host silence Akiane we're
on-site at the beautiful transformative
technology conference for a second
annual partnership with them we are now
going to be talking about circadian
rhythms and much more we have dr. Roy
Raymond joining us on the show
hi Roy hi thank you for inviting me over
here we're super pumped to talk about
the subject with you it's such a crucial
one it's a crucial one so as so we in
this kind of era has so that nobody gets
enough sleep so economic machinery is
pumping it's it's it's all about a so
being in the present and being alive and
doing the things you want you has so and
and and the fear of missing out of
everything yeah
well sleep is actually the greatest
thing you can do yeah yeah I'm so pumped
to talk about this with you this is
extremely important and actually Matt
Walker has been a huge influence in my
life a law in this field I love Matt and
I work together has in the past so he's
a great advocate for sleep as well he
really brought a topic to a level that
everybody can understand and knows that
it's important and Sachin and has also
done a great job yeah this field as well
yeah you guys are huge and I'm pumped to
talk to you about it Roy let's um let's
jump in though with one of our favorite
questions that we like asking our guests
are we really all one it's a very
interesting question has so because so I
have a more biological background and
from a biological perspective as so I
should say like yes so we build of the
same material so we should be one but
and so also from all the research that
have been doing in the past and so I
note
a lot of things that we try for instance
who helps the people sleep better work
for some and don't work for others so I
think yes sir if you would come back as
so do this great planet Earth has sir in
a thousand years you would be kind of
shocked of how we now look as how it
looked in this era on how the human
being is because we know only tiny tiny
pieces of what we are be we are as a
human being so yes we're one no we're
not one wait when's where's the not one
part so the not but you can see it as a
totally different kind of skews from has
built of the same material and so I can
have a green car and blue car in a car
that's running on either so an
electrical power and gas power so and I
think that's fair so if you use that
kind of analogy and so you can have
silly in different car but they are all
cars and so and this is the same
actually I think for human being we are
wired differently so we have all a brain
but all brains are wired different
definitely so I don't think the same way
as you are doing and so and that's also
where experience comes in and so nurture
comes in so building building blocks are
the same but then in the end so we all
end up as individuals so and then we're
no longer one ok interesting so it's
kind of like the we are all one from the
very source or from God or creation or
Big Bang or whatever you want to call it
and then there's this complexity that
evolves over time although it's the same
building blocks
it is these different subjective
first-person experiences that we have as
nerve endings of this creation yeah so
as so it's and it's it's it's already
had so it's already starting in the
wound path so where all those
connections are created so and so same
material but sometimes different wiring
and sometimes different as an experience
that's creators to have to be the unique
individuals that we are so then but at
the same time even if you have an
experience that is maybe some sort of a
very impactful experience very upstream
in your life some sort of maybe a
traumatic experience that you later find
was a very that had a beautiful treasure
on the other side of it although I may
not have had that same experience in in
in my life being still one in the sense
that as a collective as a unity we had
that experience we collectively had your
experience yeah and so but I also
believe that as so unless you got that
real experience as so it's very hard to
really kind of so have that inside and
it's empathy answer what's really going
on yeah
and so because you needed experience to
actually see what happens to you but it
comes back to a great philosophical
question and for instance and so we all
say that this is blue and so the color
here but you might perceive as so it is
being green but we label it as blue I do
not know whether you will see it as the
same do as I do and so of course our
measurements and we can do that right
now but again I think if we come back
and so to this earth has see the state
of science that what we know about you
the complex a human being and so it will
be totally different so what do you
think's the purpose of creation the
purpose of creation you need to explain
me a little bit more has or what do you
mean by creation or what is the purpose
of source or of this reality that we're
in oh that's a very philosophical one
for me I what I said is I'm very has of
Gaia logical determined so I think
that's for everybody has on earth also
will have their kind of different kind
of purpose or different kind of meaning
in life as so I always get a little bit
scared everything of those things so
like oh hi sorry I'm alive and it starts
and it ends and what will be what was
before it and what will be as so after
we die I do not know that's also why I
want to live in the present and live in
now because I can cross the street there
might be a driver he might hit me and
then he'll so what's next
I do not know so I I hope that the
purpose of life is so that and so you
live and you learn and you might take
that as so to a next level
but being a scientist so I have no
evidence and so there will be a next
level so it's very hard for me also from
a rationalist aspect you kind of think
there would be and then what about these
states of interconnectedness that you
maybe have felt or egodeath or
unconditional love or deep present tell
us about your experiences with that yeah
so I always it's again it's I have a lot
of experience with those kind of moments
that you has a really think hater should
be an extra power has so that made this
happen so but it's interesting how kind
of restricted and you are has so being
wired as you are by education has so so
to kind of just kind of put it aside
okay I cannot rationalize it so you kind
of put it aside while actually he has so
it would be interesting to dive a little
bit deeper into it but probably had
because I also know we don't have the
tools at this moment to assess those
kind of things is it there come the
restaurant rational guy again as so
bumping up has so let's put it aside
because for me as a biological
biological has so guided think
everything is determined and by biology
I hope I can return to this planet in
500 years so that I can see what tools
we have to kind of see and understand
all the things that I cannot explain
right now and so for instance one of
those great moments and there was
definitely a purpose to it and so I was
going to travel to a very big city I
didn't know how I was just there I think
for a conference and so and I met one of
my old friends from high school which he
had no reason to be there
so but we connected again and so and
it's a big city so what are the odds and
the chances that you actually in a big
city run into each other so these are
minimal and so and that's the things
that I think okay this is something
there is a meaning to that one I do not
know I also do not know who controls it
but but
it's telling me something and I think so
that's really true
but we really at this moment don't have
tools like what made it happen why did
it happen and I know what the meaning
was because now we're connected again
and we lost that connection and there
was a great reason to be connected again
because we had a great connection in the
past we just lost because life to the
different term so then something that's
crucial as we figure out what we're
uniquely blueprinted for what our gifts
are that we want to bring to the world
as we go through that process something
that we have to get right is the way
that we have this process of self love
self appreciation and a great big part
of that is how we sleep how we eat how
we exercise how we nourish our emotions
how we could show up in the world to
bring these gifts forward what are some
of the things that you've been noticing
about circadian rhythms about how the
economic machinery affects circadian
rhythms about how sleep can actually
help bring these beautiful gifts into
the world yes it's it's I think it's
great you already bring it up you need
to see it in a cultural perspective and
so the biology is the same and so the
biology is a very old ancient clock so
that's called a biological clock it has
been untrained Tessar thousand and
thousand over thousand years as they're
like light input is important and so to
kind of set your body as how to sync
with the day/night circle and then hey
we should sleep at night so that's a
great system and a system kind of loves
regularity yeah so and you definitely
see it in the Western societies that
people don't listen don't follow that
anymore so they're not listening to
their body anymore yeah so when they
feel tired they grab a Coke or a coffee
yeah so actually the body is telling you
you should take rest
yeah and so we set an alarm clock that
stupid times yeah and so we even have
things like a daylight savings times
which just
make sure that your body runs for the
economy further and that's kind of
stupid because we have been blue
printers has so to listen to our bodies
to wake up as a when the Sun rises and
when it gets a little bit warmer to
steep when it gets a little bit cooler
at night s so are we ignoring all those
kind of signs at this moment so if you
go to culture says so where and so the
economic pressure has so and the
lifestyle is not that busy
you see totally different patterns and
so you see the same kind of basic
patterns but you see not that people are
trying to kind of hair so putting
everything into the daily life and being
awake and not missing out on anything
else oh the fear of missing out so it's
we need to be a good spouse you need to
be also great and I have a professional
output you need to spend time with your
spouse that you care should have you to
have yourself time I need to need to
watch your movie there is Netflix so you
need to put at all hand so in 24 hours
and I'd always thought like wouldn't it
be great if the day would start with
sleep because if it would start with
sleep you can say okay let's schedule
eight hours for sleep and then let's see
what the rest is but now sleep is at the
end of the day so we are procrastinating
procrastinating and like oh no I need to
do that email oh no I need to spend some
quality time I need to call my mom and
so because you need to check all those
boxes and maybe has our body has so
we'll get used to that in a few thousand
years because we evolved bodies don't
have a revolution they have an evolution
evolution takes time yeah so I do not
know whether it happens I will not be
around I don't know whether I want to be
around so if sleep was not an important
evolution would already have taken care
of it that we only would need sleep for
four hours but that didn't happen
Wow yeah this is so crucial it's that
you sleep as part of evolution has
come with this really beautiful input of
you get light source you get this
process of like saving what's being
stored in the nervous system in this
memory of this vehicle you get this
light and night cycle that happens night
and day cycle that happens with the Sun
that the biological machinery sort of
follows and then like you describe it's
as though then in today's modern day now
it went from having a first eight hours
no matter what only scheduled for sleep
and the other sixteen hours as to
whatever - now let's do as much
productive work as possible now with all
of the different things that we have to
check in and then if I only sleep for
six hours no problem just sacrifice to
sleep but sleep is so important for our
body to actually be in a state of peak
wellness and peak ability to actually be
productive it's actually more
detrimental to have less sleep it's less
productive the next day it's ridiculous
you're kind of repeating red so what my
first mentor said when I did my first
step in a PhD has so he said like Roy
don't stay late and it's kind of
interesting that you kind of hear and of
course that was Europe and so he said
don't stay late because whatever you do
as for after six o'clock and so you can
do tomorrow answer probably in a quarter
of the time and so you're actually
wasting time and so to try to be
productive as until very late
it's just a waste of time you're crazy
or your body needs to have a recovery
and leisure time and so to everything
what you have learned throughout a day
and not great experiments so that have
been done that people try to solve a
puzzle a very complex one they didn't do
so they slept a night and then the
morning they were given a puzzle again
and they solved it within five minutes
because the inside that was created has
so try out a night hazard because that's
what your brain is doing it's kind of
all the information that you have
processed throughout the night has so
taking away all the things that are not
necessarily and then organizing them and
then connecting the dots so learning
happens throughout the night emotional
processing happens during sleep so
it's not only bubbly recovery it's a lot
of mental has an emotional processing
that happens as well your brain is
pretty busy when you're asleep oh yeah
oh so damn busy and those the sleep
spindles are so interesting yeah I know
those are so fascinating and just like
the body's ability to like click the
Save button on all of the previous data
that you got the day I love how I'm like
you said that you're it was your perfet
it was your professor that's it yeah
it's so interesting that if you stay
late that you're gonna take four times
potentially more time doing the material
that you would just the next day in your
peak State that's such an important
feedback actually so the main thing is
that I also say to tattoo college
students says so if you really want to
learn has her things and as so
everything that you has so takes you're
in class and and really take it and so
as something in your backpack for the
rest of your life you need to has be
very well rested when you go through all
the study materials and then you need to
get into your hands for your bed early
and then sleep on it yeah so what you
see a lot of students doing and so
they're having a lot of fun having rush
it through the book into textbook don't
sleep as so at all for hours before the
exam so it doesn't transfer to long-term
memory yes so it's just and again it's a
waste of time so and that says so sleep
has not been valued ever has so also
because we really didn't know how a lot
about the function of sleep because
sleep science is very young as I think
it started I think back in the in the
50s of the 20th century that we could
kind of quantify sleep and of course the
Greek philosophers already had great
thoughts about sleep on what does sleep
would do any sound like hey and so and
so if you're if your body is warm answer
then it's alive and when the temperature
is cold and it's dead and somewhere in
between and it's sleep and because your
body drops as so in temperature
throughout the night and so in they saw
they have already had kind of great
things but it didn't describe it as so
in a way that so he's as good it is
right now because we now have new
technology
to kind of capture what's really
happening and it's again come I want to
come back to this planet in 300 years
and see what technology can do them okay
I'm so so curious now like what can we
do look what a sleep score labs doing
yeah so we are kind of giving her so a
sleep lab has so to the end consumer or
to the people in the world and so we see
that it was a big problem so 2/3 of the
people have reporting that they don't
had a great night as so at least a few
times in a week so 50% of the people are
sorry that's 50% of the people don't
hitting the required minimum of 7 hours
and so and we were thinking it kind of
as the way that you think about obesity
or being overweight yeah so we want to
give a tool and so that tool is a so
that what is what we created so people
have a scale in their bathroom so he can
actually has so be on the scale and see
okay now I need to go for a week for
house or having salads for lunch and
skip the fries and the burgers so you
didn't have even a doctor didn't have
the tools so the medical doctor didn't
have the tool to measure sleep and so on
the fly you had to go to a lab and then
they put all kinds of wires on your
brain and you had to sleep in a hospital
bed which is not a natural situation at
all so so that was step one so giving
tools to people that they can measure
sleep and also making a very simple
matrix so because it's the indoor
comfort of their homes in the comfort of
their home and then they get metrics on
their own sleep so and we we wanted to
try to keep it as simple as as so that
you see the weight on your waiting
skills they're not saying like hey it
was 20% REM and 15% deep so and that
whole list of that sleep doctors
normally give you we just have a sleep
score that kind of has so calculates all
those important elements so it's a score
from 0 to 100 and over time you kind of
learn what what a sleep score is that's
good for you and for me I personally
know I'm a good sleeper but if for some
reasons I hit 75 three nines in a row
then I need to take care to the next day
has so and get some XYZ which is like
the salad instead of the burger like
yeah yes but we also kind of note is
that which in some cases is kind of like
just not like either going to bed really
early or just making it so that maybe
you're not waking up to an alarm in the
morning maybe you're really just letting
your body naturally awake yeah I'm when
it's well rested yeah for a body it's
better for a body for all process
consistency is best so but consistency
is also a very dull life yeah if you
would go to bed so at the same time
everyday wake up at the same time every
day have your breakfast at the same time
as I have your lunch at the same time
have them even your beer at the same
time every day and your coffee body
would love that because they the body
doesn't need to adjust anything back oh
it runs on my schedule that's great
and so but luckily we're human being the
body also wants dynamicism as well
it wants both on a different level
heavier for instance there are hardly
any animals with insomnia why they go to
sleep when they're feel tired when they
feel tired not not I need to finish this
report I need a coke or a coffee yeah
yeah or hey yeah that other Netflix
episode I would love to see it oh and it
was a great cliffhanger let's do the
other one so that's why it has so and so
and sometimes they might find themselves
in an area in nature where they may only
be unfamiliar and then they can't
necessarily go to sleep because of
danger and they have to go yes yeah only
if you're in danger so what you're not
seeing is actually has so we putting our
bodies in a dangerous state every single
time yeah yeah yeah because oh you
saying to your body I cannot sleep the
body in terms that there is a reason
that I can yeah so interesting so we're
actually triggering or physiology
against what it's trying to get us to do
and through that process we're actually
causing some sort of physiological
confusion of what's going on because
there's actually nothing to [ __ ] be
in danger about whatsoever in
buildings but even your biological clock
yeah so has so who who gets the
information has so of the light and so
we've has so the new artificial light oh
it's still awake it's still awake it's
still daytime it's time because the
biological clock sends them to all the
other clock says so in the body hey it's
still daytime screen time especially now
- oh my god so and that's that says so
what kind of it's not how it has been
designed so even when the sun's goes
down at like five or six o'clock
sometimes during yeah p.m. and now
during the winter
holy cow now we're watching screens for
like six or seven more hours past the
Sun going down I need to ask you about
the Sun because you started teaching us
about what you're doing and I just want
to I just want to UM see so am I wearing
is this a wearable no you know how so
coming back house or what we were in the
end just like you do weight management
and beyond your skill every single day
we won't love to actually answer with a
simple metrics and to measure your sleep
and we make it relatively easy because
we also believe that sleep is all about
comfort so you don't want to have
devices in your bed or on your wrist or
in your head so we have a device that
you just put next to your house or two
on your nightstand so it is totally
contact glass so we have a device has so
but since last year we also launched has
so something that you can use just on
your iPhone how does this work the the
device on the smartphone or there's a
measure my sleep if it yeah so that's
where a lot of as so a signal processing
and knowledge about sleep comes in so
what really happens is let's a watch me
know well because hey sorry you don't
want to be watching your bedtime so has
or even be listen to us as our mother
comes so now what we do has so it's it's
the device is sending a radar wave a
very low energy radar wave lower than
Bluetooth and so net balances of your
body so and by doing so we measure your
full breathing pattern and so in your
full motion better whoa all the
different sleep stages has
have slightly different breeding
patterns of motion panels so with a lot
of algorithm work and we actually a
sleep score labs so have an algorithm
and we validated that against the gold
standard and we doing has so very good
so so that's what we did we also phones
can actually propagate out radar signals
so that's the hardware that's the
hardware device and then we find out
like a lot of people are actually not
willing to pay as a 150 bucks for sleep
measurement so so that's why last year
we launched sonar technology has so from
phones so what we do is we use actually
the speaker and the microphone off has
so the smartphone so the smartphone
sends out has so hardly noticeable and
for most people not noticeable
noticeable sound waves so that all again
bounces back off your body back to has
the microphone and we get the same
signals for house or breathing emotion
wait okay so a unnoticeable frequency of
sound is emitted from the device and
then it bounces off of me yeah and you
can measure my full reading rate my
chest breathing rate so so you actually
what you measure is the movement of your
body so you measure the movement of your
chest cavity as so the gross movement or
your tossing and turning so and then
there's a a way for you to be able to
tell how long I'm sleeping how well I'm
sleeping yeah because all those
different eyes so the the difference is
a movement and the difference is
inbreeding and so relate to different
sleep stages light sleep and deep sleep
and REM sleep so and then we actually in
the end can see like okay so you spend
as that amount of time it took you so
many minutes to fall asleep so again we
think that's great information for the
doctor and maybe for the house or the
biohackers so but for the end consumer
we just presented as a single number so
that there's something easy you kind of
know like okay for me
Haiti is my number and I go for it so
I'm just doing something as simple as
downloading the sleep score labs app
yeah yeah
as simple as that and you put how your
phone next to you better so has so at
night but one thing I want to has ads we
don't believe that has so it's all about
measurement and the measurement should
be great but people are looking actually
has so into things that really can
improve your sleep so and we in the
sleep field called it as the so called
so what problem so now you know your
sleep score what should you do most
simple just go to bed and sleep actually
get more sleep is that not the most
simple thing it's the most simple thing
but hey if you were taking for instance
four cups of coffee after four o'clock
that's horrible that will be hard and a
lot of people actually do not know so we
give them a full toolbox as so as well
like so we say like okay this is what we
see in in your data and so and this is
given as what we see in your data that
we think at this moment will work best
for you to improve your sleep and so and
we connect you to either that kind of
tips and tricks based also on your
personal sleep or we even connect you to
products and the great thing with the
products is that has so we curated them
and we even validate them we do a lot of
studies for manufacturers and kind of
showing them that their products are
evidence-based as so they say like hey
we think it or we believe it improve
sleep and we say show us the data and if
they don't have it we say okay we can
provide you the data so we do studies
and you can actually say and so hey it
has been tested by sleep collapse and
sleep scholars has shown that it's
really as are improving sleep of people
yeah because unfortunately in the world
of sleep there's a lot of snake oil so
you can body yeah yeah okay so this is
great the hardware partners one are just
other partners is very interesting for
improving sleep I like that a lot and
being able to prove with your sleep
score that if they do or not and then
just in general I just I'm finding of
course all this stuff with digital
signal processing actually being able to
propagate out the sound wave and gain
some sort of an understanding of what's
being you're calibrating back from that
process that parts and nuts and then is
it is it pretty like
clear for you guys to see whether or not
I'm actually getting like eight hours of
sleep compared to six like it's very
clear for you guys to show a sleep score
that's significantly higher for someone
that's sleeping eight hours like it's
it's like it's that clear
yeah so because we the the data that we
kind of has so has our estimate from all
our signals has been validated against
the clinical way of measuring sleep the
great thing is so and that's what we do
down in the back end as well is we now
collecting a huge data set of people
sleeping in the real home situation and
so and I was kind of shocked when I
first saw had that kind of data because
it's kind of so different than from all
the things that we know from small
studies that have been carried out by
sleep researchers in the hospital
settings or in the laboratory settings
because people sleep differently in home
situation than they sleep in a lab yes
and that's why we also want to kind of
progress a certain knowledge and sleep
and so getting a lot of data on how
people extra sleeper so because you
might have a partner your partner snores
you know that impacts you that partner
will never be with you in a sleep study
or in there so in any kind of study
because that's not how the scientific or
the academic model of doing studies
works and in the end we have that data
and the most most likely contacts data
and so we know that you sleep with a
partner has so that's Norris and of
course they need to consensus so that we
get an information so it's not that we
had just collected all the information
as so by just opening a microphone
that's not what we're doing here so we
we don't want to so but we building this
kind of new data set of what we call in
science terms ecologically valid has so
data so it's really measured in the
field and so with real people of real
daily life or daily night situations I
really thought what you were saying was
so interesting also about how when we
sleep next to a partner that also
drastically changes how we sleep
literally
to another like human being in the same
bed
some people go and choose to sleep in
different rooms even though there may be
in the relationship and then there's
this big data set that you have what
others like first like let's hear your
thoughts about lake sleeping in
different areas and then also I'd like
to hear your thoughts about like what
you can also do with data on people that
are that are like longitudinally that
you're improving their sleep and then
where other insights can come from data
yes actually has a two questions let's
start where the first one sleeping
together and so it's again interestingly
a very under study topic because most of
the sleep researcher says so have a
single person in a bed when they study
yes so what we kind of know and I think
there have been two studies in the past
that really were measuring brain waves
and it was kind of inconclusive and so
one study said like okay yeah so the
partner was the man were sleeping better
than the women in general and so another
study I think saw that there was some
sinking in this in the sleep stages and
so but I would say it's kind of income
inconclusive a big factor though is that
so people find just hazards they're
feeling that they find more safe and so
being close to someone else and so it's
the present of sorts presence of someone
else Wow both in the mind but also you
you feel it physically because it's the
warm that you radiate that's that
cuddling effect yeah so and you see it
has also in a lot of of mammals and so
they sleep together and it's not only
because of energy conversation
conversation conservation energy
conservation and temperature has our
energy usage but also because they feel
safe together yeah and so that that's
that's that's interesting so but wow if
you're a light sleeper your partner
snores or you're a light sleeper and
very restful and your partner has so is
or if you're just on different like you
go to bed two hours later and wake up
two hours later yeah so then as it might
be actually a good idea as so
just as so sleep for a few nights of
these as so separate as so and so you
just have two bedrooms and has me being
up late at night is not affecting them
then waking up early is not directing me
yeah so some people and also that's
anecdotal I said hey it had also great
impact on our sex life because then it
was really special has on the moment
that they went to bed and get together
again so yeah that's everything -
interesting
um how about how feedback I know I know
the whole data point maybe we can get to
it
just given the amount of other questions
that I think I that I would like
answered there's um this one you were
giving this example of stop drinking
coffee after like four o'clock right
stuff like that or another one is you
know people say are like don't eat this
last meal yeah like midnight you know
like that yeah so give us give us these
examples for yes we did the great thing
is so you should see that as kind of
general guidelines as so and it might
work for you and it doesn't might not
work for some someone yells but it's and
I think that's where we also need to
think of so there are a lot of
guidelines so if you really look into
the literature if there is there is
there any empirical evidence that is
really work so it's is really limited so
again it's not that well studied and why
because it's very hard to study so but
for me for instance I know that I'm
relatively caffeine insensitive so I can
have a double shot of espresso at 10
o'clock at night so and I sleep very
well it has to do as so with the
consolation of my DNA a my caffeine
sensitivity other people might not so so
the general rule is to be on the safe
side don't drink caffeine has so after
three o clock as so avoid spicy meals as
so as so because spicy meals can do
things that actually keep you awake and
keep your body on a current kind of
higher arousal level but you can't
imagine that if you were raised as so in
having a jello pee no pepper in every
single meal you'll be fine
you will be fine so okay okay
and then let's talk about all the data
so then what do you how many people are
using sleep score labs right now yes so
as so in interesting answer that's kind
of has a business confidential
information because we have properties
of competitors but and so our data set
and our analysis easily has so go over
and so are using 5000 people hazard n
spending as so a million nights and
doing the study has so where you say
like hey and so I have 20 people as on
f2 nights and I think that's where the
difference is so for instance if I do an
intervention study in an academia
setting and so they measure you one
night so then you take so the
intervention then you come back and they
measure you another night that might be
a very bad night for you for all the
other things so that might it might be
happening in your life and so and I
always use a very old-fashioned example
like you know those old computers with
those dip switches so you have so set a
switch on on or off on your main board
so sleep is like having 100 dip switches
and whenever 51 are kind of set to a
favor have received and will sleep
better it can be it can be the caffeine
and the fight that you had with your
partner yeah and the email that you got
from your boss oh yeah oh poor single
answer language fine
sleep and and you're saying about overly
thinking about that issue and that's the
great thing because our technology is
not invasive and you don't need to have
the wires on your heads and so and so
much if I doze we get data night after
night after night after night so we can
see slow processes and changes as our
evolving what's approximately that the
device has to be next to me it's a it's
arm length and farm lands away yeah yeah
okay and can it be in like airplane mode
and still work yes sir that's a great
thing as so we collect all the data on
your phone and then just in the end and
so it needs a Wi-Fi connection but it
can be running anyway but you can run an
airplane mode some people just don't
want even ya want it just in airplane
mode at night or
powered off yeah new things yeah so hey
so yeah there's maybe I pay even just
like $20 for just the device that can do
what sleep score labs rather than also
have to have my phone on yeah yeah so so
that's another one technically her so
but the device isn't it was not designed
for it but technically you can start as
early device with the phone and bring
your phone to another room and so then
bring in the phone the next day so then
you don't have any phone next to you and
so yes yes that divide the phone for us
has so with the device is just the
control panel so um another question
that I have is that the future of like
productivity in the economic machinery
but also our focus on our well-being
here at tranzact this type of stuff
where are all these things converging
how do we actually have true
transformations and consciousness and
wanting to become more healthy and have
better well-being but also deal with the
pressures of the economic machinery that
are happening what is then like the
future of sleep yeah I think it's I
would even call a little bit as so
broader what is the future of life of
life as so so I think at this moment as
so that's why I love conferences like
this we think too much in silos so the
fitness guy thinks in terms of fitness
as so and the food guys or girl things
in terms of food and then I think of
sleep and so the meditation things of
meditation
I actually think so they are so
interconnected and so that we need to
have at least a few people thinking on
what if we take that more a helicopter
view or more holistic approach so that
is actually has a tagging all of these
things or at least connecting the dots
because a very simple thing you might
well have a new year Volusia new year
resolution and you say I want to as so
be embedded fitness so or has I want to
lose weight so I as a sleep guy come in
and say like hey did you actually know
that
so if you
just don't care take care about your
sleep you actually don't have the energy
has so to run that mile every every
every single day and if you don't have
enough sleep you have a preference for
more fatty and more sugary food so you
will not lose weight so it's again so I
need to learn actually as so from for
instance the fitness guy and the
meditation girl and the food guru and so
what's important from from them and then
together and so transform it rather than
stay on our silos and so in our ivory
tower and try to solve as so the problem
from a single angle I love that yeah the
super multivariate way of the future of
health and well-being I love that and
the component of sleep I mean I've again
just so many ways to take this does it
feel like humanity is a biological
bootloader for a digital super
intelligence
I don't know so and so I think I think
again that's a we're we're we're we are
evolutionary species so it doesn't go
that fast and what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in creation the
most beautiful thing for me in creation
is the unexpected and so because you do
something which so you never thought you
were able to and so then for me it's
also has so sharing that's had creation
with other people so and I think that's
as what I think are the two components
for me that are important a certain
creation it's like and so bringing
something bringing something new and so
and I'm being able to share
yeah bringing something new and being
able to share yeah look kind of takes us
to what is your unique gift that you can
bring to the world and then how do you
yet share it into the world as you
probably know as so I used to work for
Apple as soda tech company here so and I
brought a few features for sleep on
their iOS system on their phone so for
me it's kind of crazy to kind of know
that as so millions of people in the
world and so using that piece of tech
and using something that I put there for
better health and so I I had that
feature that has Nicole nightshift
that's dims the screen at night and so a
lot of people told me that was the best
feature of the died us roadies yeah and
so they didn't care about hazard at a
while sense or another camera feature
and I think that's also where tech
company says so I think getting better
in thinking of the health consequences
but also I think enough as so the
psychological consequences and so
because if I see kids and as so they are
also playing a full night with just the
screen and don't interact with other
human beings yeah yeah I rather would
take the hair sort of tablet away and so
the tablets are great but we're still
human beings we still need to have that
eyes so face to face interaction I still
has so need a hug of somebody wrong yeah
just a digital chat yeah yeah yeah
that's that's so that's so profound the
the the night the night shift or like a
flux is such a such a crucial thing that
we use that gives us a better life like
you said an actual hug rather than just
a digital chat yeah how can we use these
philosophies morals ethics as our main
principles as we build technology to
enhance our world and so I I love that I
love that so much what a great
conversation this has been thank you for
coming on thank you so much and I really
enjoyed it as well as via so if you
didn't stop we could chat for hours so
we'll be back I mean this is a big deal
I get your damn sleep everyone like yeah
it beeper because it really helps you
live your physiology better also your
productivity better the next day I mean
it's just yeah yeah yeah
get your damn sleep everyone thanks for
tuning into this episode of greatly
appreciated we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on what
we talked about let us know what you
think and also check out the links below
to sleep score labs also to Royce
profiles check out all those links in
the Bible or check out the links to
transform earth technology conference in
the bio below as well you can support
them you can support simulation you can
support other artists entrepreneurs
organizations around the world that you
believe in you can find Arlene
expel our paypal cryptocurrency patreon
link you can design cool merch and get
paid all those links around the bottle
below and go and build the future room
manifest your dreams into the world you
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon peace
[Music]
you
[Music]